un hombre libre se enfrenta al peso de
la historia
joseph fux tiene 100 años su juicio se
lleva a cabo ocho décadas después de los
actos que se le imputan
el antiguo cabo primero de las bases ss
es juzgado por complicidad en el
asesinato de tres mil 518 prisioneros en
un campo de concentración nazi el
acusado no habló durante el juicio pero
para los abogados de las partes civiles
eso no es lo esencial
la particularidad de este juicio es que
durante décadas la justicia alemana dejó
de llevar a cabo este tipo de procesos
porque sólo hasta 2009 retomó su trabajo
las víctimas que representamos comparten
un objetivo
que se siga hablando de lo que pasó en
los campos de concentración es que se
mantenga esa memoria y que al final se
pueda dictar una sentencia justa
el juicio se realiza en un gimnasio
convertido en tribunal cerca de la
residencia del acusado para evitar los
desplazamientos largos
schulz es el imputado de mayor edad
entre los acusados de crímenes nazi
según los cargos entre 1942 y 1945 fue
uno de los guardias del campo de
sachsenhausen
situado cerca de berlín un episodio que
el acusado mantuvo en secreto toda su
vida hasta que la justicia alemana lo
encontró en el centro de investigaciones
de crímenes nació ubicado en lewis burke
en el sur del país la casa de nazis aún
no ha terminado
este es nuestro archivo central
en total tiene casi 18 millones de
fichas
aquí empieza cada investigación
realizada por el centro nacional de
lewisburg
tenemos todos los acusados todos los
castigos de todas las investigaciones
hechas aquí desde finales de los años 50
desde su creación en 1958 los fiscales
del centro como michael o 'the son los
encargados de perseguir a los criminales
de guerra nazis se hicieron 130.000
juicios y más de 7000 investigaciones
preliminares que condujeron en
particular a los famosos juicios de
auschwitz en los años 1960 pero estos
últimos marcaron el final de los grandes
procesos contra los criminales de guerra
nazis la justicia recuperó sus derechos
en 2011 con el caso de john demjanjuk un
antiguo guardia del campo de exterminio
sobibor a partir de ese juicio la prueba
de una actividad en un campo de la
muerte es suficiente para condenar a los
criminales de guerra entonces los
cazadores de nazi iniciaron una carrera
contra el tiempo
el juicio de emilio nos llevó a
investigar de nuevo en detalle todos los
campos de concentración en los que se
cometieron crímenes sistemáticos
analizamos minuciosamente todos los
documentos relacionados con el personal
que trabajaba en estos campos pronto
ningún criminal estará vivo y es por eso
que estamos trabajando con una atención
especial en estos archivos
aunque tardía la justicia condenando a
cuatro antiguos miembros de las ss por
haber sido cómplices de asesinato
dictando penas a menudo simbólicas por
su avanzada edad joseph schultz también
es acusado de haber contribuido en la
maquinaria nazi por su trabajo como
guardia en el campo de sachsenhausen de
los 200.000 detenidos entre los cuales
había opositores políticos judíos
homosexuales y también prisioneros de
guerra soviéticos murió cerca de un
cuarto para una de las historiadoras a
cargo de memorial de sax sanhouse en
esta justicia no sólo es importante por
la memoria histórica es una señal
importante en el contexto político
actual en ucrania donde se está
volviendo a cometer crímenes de guerra
en europa
esto demuestra que en un estado
democrático este tipo de crímenes se
pueden juzgar mucho tiempo después de
los hechos
eso tiene que ver con la historia de la
posguerra con la historia de la justicia
pero tarde o temprano ocurre
las víctimas o sus descendientes pueden
contar con eso los criminales deben
prepararse
la fiscalía alemana condenó a cinco años
de prisión a joseph shields una decena
de presuntos criminales de guerra
todavía son objeto de investigación
preliminar en alemania actualmente todos
tienen más de 90 años